doing okay
[Music]
[Applause]
that of course is Cheech and Chong
everybody loved those guys back in the
day back in the day teach Marin is not
only famous for those stoner comedies
and other Hollywood Productions his
passion project that was collecting
Chicano art now his collection the
largest in the country has a permanent
home in Riverside California Anthony
Mason took a visit to the museum
affection called the Cheech and he got
listen to this a tour that's pretty got
a tour from the actor himself
this is kind of the centerpiece yeah
this was commissioned for the museum by
the De la Torre Brothers in the lobby
you're greeted by a 26 foot tall
lenticular installation of an Aztec
Earth goddess it almost feels alive it
is alive you could see something new
every time you look at it yeah
this is the new Cheech Marin Center for
Chicano art and culture in Riverside
California your name's over the door
yeah
is that cool I've got that in as soon as
I possibly could you know what should we
call this but the Cheech would be a good
name it's a great name I think so too it
is so gratifying that I don't really
dwell on that so much I just watch the
people come in and watch them enjoy it
all right thanks for all of you bro
we're so proud of this thank you thank
you for coming here how's that feel it's
beyond a dream you know I never dreamed
this dream it's too big a dream oh my
God look at that
look at that Cheech donated more than
500 paintings drawings and sculptures to
the new Museum that bears his name
chicanoort he says isn't a style of
painting it's more a flavor of the
Mexican-American Community
I always call the John Coltrane of
Chicano penis because he puts the paint
on with such spontaneity works by dozens
of artists like Wayne Alanis Healey I
describe it as Norman Rockwell meets
Jackson Pollock it's a drip painting but
it's figurative and this one jumped off
the wall at me I got whoa what this one
here it was a painting by Margaret
Garcia
Chicago you know
this is by Franco Romero the rest of the
paleteros the paleteros are ice cream
man so this is MacArthur Park and and
they were going to try to clean up
MacArthur Park because there was gangs
and there was trouble so what they did
is they send them the SWAT team to
arrest the ice cream man and you can see
it I mean this is like the little kids
with the Popsicles over their head who's
that guy oh that's the Chicano Mona Lisa
King of Chicano art that's really great
this is by elor Torres all the painters
at some point they go if I paint a
picture of Cheech he'll probably buy it
[Music]
born in East L.A cheats started
collecting Chicano art about 1985. it's
an addiction
my name is chich and I'm an art addict
what do you think that addiction is all
about I think it's about love of the
subject I've been a collector of
anything since I was little kid marbles
baseball cards stamps anything what's
your name isn't it on there on the
license man
yeah that's it man that's my name
Richard Cheech Marin made his name of
course as part of the cannabis infused
comedy team Cheech and Chong Mexican
Americans don't like to get up early in
the in the morning but they have to so
they do it real slow their success and
other acting roles allowed Cheech to
invest in his passion I was the perfect
storm I I knew what the art was I had
money to collect it and I had a
celebrity in order to proselytize for it
Maria Esther Fernandez is artistic
director of the Cheech he wanted this
work to be seen and I think that's where
he diverges from other collectors and so
he knocked on doors and he wasn't always
well received but he persisted ah man I
was a stoner comedian with this
collection and it was always kind of
like a push back there at the beginning
none of the museum directors wanted to
put their head on the Block it's one of
the most
wonderful Chicano expressions of
Spiritual Awakening that I've ever seen
Cheech was determined to tour his
collection taking it to some 50 museums
around the country in 2002 to the
Smithsonian and what we were saying was
his exhibit is Chicano is American
because you cannot say American without
including that part of the Latino Prime
[Music]
then in 2017 the city of Riverside with
a population more than 50 percent Latino
wanted to find a new mission for its old
Library Riverside came to you yes that
is the part that I never expected didn't
understand what they were saying at
first you want me to buy a museum I'm
doing pretty good but I don't know if
I'm Museum Rich
no no we want to give you the museum you
give us the collection we'll take care
of it we'll be okay you know let's go
and jump off the cliff you know and then
away we went after a nearly 13 million
dollar renovation the Cheech was born
and then this goes around and it's been
dipped in blood all these Hearts oh
how does this rank with
your movies oh your comedy you know I'm
equally proud of both but the pride that
emanates from this one is is beyond
anything
Cheech is still making movies three in
the last year alone including the
romantic comedy shotgun wedding are you
still collecting yeah
I don't even try not to you know I mean
I'll fake it anymore because I I'm not a
zillionaire to say hey send over two
tons of that art you know and that's why
I work all the time I work at home I can
get that painting because there's still
masterpieces of Chicano are being made
by the best artists right now but
there's no Greater Joy than standing in
front of a new painting like wow
cool you know that's the best part of it
and now he's sharing it with everybody I
gotta tell you I love this Museum the
art is fabulous the building is great
it's about an hour east of LA totally
worth the trip take it it's really a
landmark because I there's no other
Museum in the country like it well you
can see his passion for it too I love
how it came about when he said you know
I'm doing okay but I don't know if I'm a
museum museum I hope I could do that but
basically he had the collection they had
the building and they said come and
bring it and it it's all the result of
all his work and his love of all of
these artists and building them up
you've been known to collect a piece or
two anything in there you'd like to take
home listen I went to cheech's house
once I wanted to take it all home I mean
he's got a great eye and and it's just
great stuff yeah so much clips of seeing
him back in the day you can't help but
crack up yeah it's so funny thank you
Anthony always good to see you we'll be
right back
[Music]